Sicario to cease release this week so to
celebrate I decided to re-watch the
first film and the phenomenal franchise
to bring you a recap where things left
off as well as my explanation on the
film's ending throughout this video
there will be heavy spoilers and I
highly recommend that you check this
film out if you haven't yet with that
out the way and definition and this is
my ending explanation of Sicario
throughout Sicario we follow FBI agent
Kate macer as she works with the CIA in
order to take down drug cartel
operations teaming with the shadowy CIA
agent Matt graver and Alejandro Gillick
who slowly discovers that things aren't
what they seem and because of this gets
thrown into the middle of the crosshairs
in the film's final half-hour we
discovered that the CIA have only been
used in capers status as an FBI agent
and this is because the CIA requires
cooperation from another agency in order
to operate within the u.s. kate comes to
the realization that she's been set up
as a patsy but still insists on joining
the raid on the tunnel in order to find
out more and ensure things go by the
book the team kills all of the men in
the tunnel and Alejandro reaches the
other end where he kidnaps one of Diaz's
drug mules when kate arrives and
attempts to stop alejandro he shoots her
bulletproof vest which momentarily
paralyzes her and allows him to continue
on his mission
returning to the tunnel entrance kate
confronts man who explains that by
disabling the Sonora cartel they are
attempting to return to a
single-car tell the Medellin brand the
drug trade this would ultimately return
order to the industry and thus reduce
violence and until Americans stop using
cocaine this is the best that they can
hope for Alejandro who worked for the
Medellin was brought on to assassinate
Alec on mat explains decay that Alec on
had ordered the murder of Alejandro's
wife and daughter and this is
Alejandro's opportunity for revenge
in Mexico Alejandra reaches a lakhan's
estate and he finds his family at their
dinner table killing them in front of
alekan before killing him too after the
completion of the mission Alejandro
appears in Kate's apartment where he
forces her gunpoint to sign a waiver
legitimizing the operation as he leaves
she aims her pistol at him but as he
makes eye contact with her she realizes
she cannot bring herself to pull the
trigger Alejandra warned Kate that she
was not go out to live amongst the
wolves and the lowering of her gun
confirms this this also highlights why
the character will not return for the
sequel in Juarez we watch victims of
Alejandro's watch his son soccer game
the game is briefly interrupted by the
sound of gunfire before continuing this
signifies that the violence will
continue once more and it will be the
innocents who are left to suffer at its
heart this is a tale of the death of
one's family and how leading a violent
life will always lead to tragedy
Alejandro's family were killed which led
him to murder members of other peoples
and it warns how dangerous drugs could
be at the film's heart is the theme that
if everyone just stopped using drugs or
if the government legalized it which
they are clearly prepared to consider
due to their actions in the movie then
this violence would go away and stop
leaking into effect those who have no
influence on it it's a deep message and
one of the most brilliant aspects of the
film so what did you think of Sicario is
there anything I missed out or did you
interpret the film differently comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please like and
subscribe to my channel I create content
like this weekly and they'll definitely
be something on here that
make sure you keep an eye out for my
Sicario to ending exclaim video and
check out my Luke Cage season to end the
explain video at the end of this one
again thanks very much for taking the
time to watch this and I'll see you next
time take care peace
[Music]